here is my go-to productivity hack I do
different things on different days so
Monday I spend the entire day mentoring
my team Tuesday I'm doing YouTube videos
Wednesday is my project day where I open
it up to work on whatever projects I
want to work on those things that are on
your to-do list that never get done
that's Wednesday Thursday is my public
facing day I start the day doing
training with my community and then I'm
doing podcast and interviews the rest of
the day Friday is my CEO day where I
focus on being the CEO of my business
and building the connections with the
people that I need to stay in touch with
because as an introvert I forget to stay
in touch with people so that's my Friday
afternoons Saturday is my fun day where
I spend the day with my wife Nina with
my family thinking of things of how we
can have fun this weekend and then
Sunday is family admin day where we do
laundry and grocery shopping all the
things that you have to do to run your
life having different days dedicated to
different things makes me a lot more
productive I would love to know what
your productivity hack is in the
comments below